foreign
[Music]
CBS deals this morning we have a few
deals if you're looking to relax or do a
little spring cleaning this summer and
all at exclusive low prices to start
shopping now scan the QR code on your
screen or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert Elizabeth
Warner joins us with more good morning
good morning all right are you ready we
got quite a mixture here we do we're
going to start off with true medic now
I'm going to hand this to you because
you have to see it to believe it we're
going to turn it on you notice there are
no wires here this is going to help all
of us with our sore tired achy muscles
this has a rechargeable battery
go ahead it so you got the quads going
you're back you're wherever you've got
sore muscles or those tight knots in the
tissue multiple different massage heads
come with this it's in a carry case and
it's actually designed to travel with
you no longer do you have to go to the
physical therapist or to the massage
therapist where it's so much money for
less than the cost of one massage we can
work on those tired achy muscles this is
starting off at 79.99 up to 53 off so
after a workout after a stressful day
whatever it might be why you need these
These are going to travel with you and I
love the carry case so it goes with me
when I travel here I've got it with me
now Sharper Image table top fire pit
this is amazing a mini fire a mini fire
pit so this is going to go when you're
outside you're having a barbecue a
picnic date night with your wife you're
going to add in your alcohol just
rubbing alcohol and then we use a long
lighter to actually light it it
instantly is going to glow and give us
that gorgeous warmth it's reinforced
concrete on the outside so it can hand
that handle that heat odorless smoke
free and yes you can even cook over it
so make those gooey yummy delicious
s'mores you can do that with this so I'm
told we're not supposed to start a fire
hear what I'm going we're not supposed
to start a fire in here remember safety
first Safety First
these are
26.79 33 off my husband and I just had
date night with it sat outside made a
nice dinner perfect it's a small little
limb it's perfect so relevant this is a
gorgeous gorgeous skin care line the
creator of this actually your family
comes from Kenya and her grandparents
taught her all about globally sourced
ingredients whether it was coffee bean
seed oil banana extract to use those
things on our skin well this balm is
amazing it is a cleansing balm we take
it there I am actually applying it
myself rub it all over the face not only
does it clean your face it takes off 100
of your makeup the mascara that you
never get off the lip stain I after TV I
have so much makeup on I wash my face
100 times and I can't get it off this
solves that problem a beautiful
cleansing serum all of these actually
really create beautiful face when you're
done as well it helps with your fine
lines your wrinkles and I love the eye
serum this one we open up it's got a
ceramic a beautiful applicator we place
it under the eyes oh my goodness this
helps get rid of the puffiness the dark
circles here here take it and try it yes
this is just rub this one all over your
face
rub it on your face and you rinse it off
so these are starting at just
21.25 off she has an entire skin care
line on cbsdeals.com shop for all of it
because it makes an amazing difference
in the face now let's get to the
honeydew list we all have to clean our
houses and we don't want to hire the
professionals to do that restorative
cleaning the grout your floors well
cleanies has been created so that now we
get the professional but we don't need
the actual professional we get the
professional cleaners so we can do this
for ourselves at home for our grout
we're going to actually just spray that
on the grout let it sit it five to ten
minutes it comes with the two brushes an
exclusive bundle just for us and we're
going to watch all of that grout come
clean not only the outer layer of dirt
goes away but it penetrates into the
grout to actually pull those stains out
so think about the grout in your house
your showers that's my hubby doing the
floor
that's him that's my hubby doing the
floors he's doing the the grout there
and then they also have something called
restore ease so I'm going to just squirt
this down here on this wood floor
whether you have wood floors vinyl
laminate you name it we're going to be
able to restore those floors it comes
with this Jeff you should be doing that
oh sure you did it I didn't microfiber
applicator all right here you go you do
it here we are and this I think that's
that's good okay I think you can do your
whole house with that there you go here
you go all right now you're gonna rub
that in now this breathes life right
into your floors how much is this
Elizabeth nice and shiny and bright
again 25.94
chance to start up to 46 off and you can
clean anything in your house with the
clean ease products they are amazing
nice excellent
um thank you very much I messed this up
a little bit
um we've partnered with all these
companies to get these deals to buy
anything you saw today scan the QR code
on your screen or head over to CBS deals
dot com